three
[Music]
days
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
because we're
[Music]
foreign
online
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
fight
[Music]
early
thank you
[Music]
very much
never mind
[Music]
[Applause]
whole uh returning you guys
[Music]
definitely behind me foreign
one vehicle
we're starting ahead
3326 fell foreign
[Music]
foreign
I'm gonna come around this side and
we're gonna open that door
I have a canine
Panzer up I can see Hands Up passenger
side
where's the female hands are up that
passenger door
Sam come on out I can't come out
come on come on slowly ma'am come back
do not move you want me to try passenger
side
she's out she's out
put their hands up
keep your hands up be quiet
you want me to get hell again
let's cut it okay I'm here except for me
keep your hands up don't you dare move
ment
I swear to God do not move it's not
moving sir hands are clear hands are
clear not the dog bite you if you do
up
guys
can't get this with the snow bank
I'm back at tester's vehicle up
move we need to move your vehicle
yourself
keep those hands up
help me
climb over and climate faster
what
come over the passenger side now with
your hands up as much as you can come
out this side slowly
slowly
just slowly
start climbing over slowly and come out
try to keep your hands up as far as you
can okay
keep your hands up and slowly climb over
okay all right
keep coming keep coming keep coming down
keep coming soon
oh
I'm not doing anything
yeah the only man that's a handicapped
so
gentlemen
did somebody go check on the victim
she was requesting water if anybody has
water thank you Jesus what's going on
geez this car right here passengers cage
person
foreign
no no
any weapons on you no sir knife anything
pocket right here this is my oh my uh
he's advising no injuries we got gloves
on you
okay
there's all kinds of stuff
let me hey let me go with gloves oh
Ron yeah I might have struck something
that came off of either yours or state
Squad okay
I'm just letting you know now wherever
he broke down he put me down for about
10 hours
foreign
oh
any injuries other than your wrist
hurting from the handcuffs my whole left
side
the adrenaline's really you're having
pain on your left side yeah
Ron have EMS come here you go I'm coming
okay
oh what first side pain that's what he's
telling me he says he has too much
adrenaline right now oh
I'm fixing to tell me 50.
oh
all right I asked EMS to make sure he
was verified bring somebody for her to
get checked out too she's really shaken
up and then she asked for water if we
could get her water awesome thank you
all right this tank is clear
all right we're gonna roll over on this
side okay then we're gonna sit up okay
ready come on now get your knees
underneath you
all right
okay
oh wherever yours is
I actually I think I got a flat tire my
tire we just put them in your squad for
now okay we can adjust
yeah I got I'm off the rim dude
[Applause]
Ron you want blystones for our Squad
Josh's tires
yeah
33 30.
33 30 can you start blysons to our
location for a squad
let's start to
additionally start two toes